Parliament approved the nomination of  Christine Lagarde as the European  Central Bank's next president with 394  votes in favour 206 against and 49  abstentions she is due to take up the  post on the 1st of November  research and youth mobility across the  EU are getting a financial boost members  voted for a hundred million euro top-up  for two flagship programmes horizon 2020  and erasmus+ the UK is due to leave the  European Union on the 31st of October  Mme peas reiterated their support for an  orderly brexit and pledged to reject any  withdrawal agreement without a backstop  MEP s approved two hundred and ninety  three point five million euros from the  European Union Solidarity fund to assist  reconstruction in Italy Austria and  Romania following devastating floods and  landslides in 2018 fires have destroyed  more than 900,000 hectares of forests in  the Amazon this year MEP has discussed  what action to take to restore and  protect forests worldwide